[Applaudissements]
pour montrer que la situation des
intermittents et difficile en ce moment
pour nous et du coup il faut que le
gouvernement prendre des mesures comme
pour les grandes entreprises du cac 40
donc nous aussi la culture est en danger
et il faut que
ils prennent des mesures en pensant à
nous surtout qu'on ait une minorité et
donc du coup même si des fois on essaie
de nous faire passer pour des
responsables par exemple après
l'assurance chômage mais au final non
vraiment une minorité on représente pas
beaucoup de gens les intermittents donc
du coup il faut que le gouvernement nous
aide les professionnels du spectacle
dans une situation catastrophique depuis
le mois de mars certains n'ont pas pu
travailler parce que les interdictions à
ouvrir les lieux publics donc et partira
en spectacle de façon complètement
inéquitable d'ailleurs et donc nous nous
avons déçu des gens qui sont en
situation sociale extrêmement dégradée
on a des gens qui sont en train de
devenir de la paupérisation de nos
professions et même noter par rapport
des nations unies donc et le
gouvernement prétend que personne ne
doit rester sans de la route dans les
fêtes il ya eu des mesures mais elles
sont totalement insuffisantes et
notamment être sont insuffisantes pour
les artistes et techniciens et
techniciennes intermittents du spectacle
pour les autres ici les auteurs qui sont
des anti qui ne vivent que de
contraintes travail discontinue ou de
contrats d'auteurs forcément aléatoire
selon la production des oeuvres
donc ça c'est inadmissible il nous faut
une garantie pour que nous puissions
avoir le droit de travailler puisque on
nous incite à faire des répétitions des
restes des résidences de création mais
que le guen n'est pas le budget pour le
permettre
il est en train de sauver les grosses
structures et il oublie la plupart de
ceux qui font le coeur de la création
qui sont les intermittents du spectacle
et les autres hisser les auteurs